this is one of several former military
bases that the government says it wants
to use to house thousands of Asylum
seekers in order to save Millions on
expensive hotels just in front of that I
believe is where they're going to be put
in the modular units yeah it's going to
be there so about the same out my
kitchen window and Sarah Carter lives
just a few meters from this proposed
site we know that not everybody that's
an asylum Seeker is is bad but you know
there's a percentage that are going to
be and they're going to bring that to us
she watched as immigration Minister
Robert generic said this new policy was
in the public interest accommodation for
migrants should meet their essential
living needs and nothing more
because we cannot risk becoming a magnet
for the millions of people who are
displaced and seeking better economic
prospects
what does today mean for you because it
looks like this plan is going ahead it
means war
it means we're going to we're starting
our fight with the home office
that's what it means
the government says four sites in total
will be used to hold around 6 000
migrants including this former prison in
Essex this video filmed just a few
months ago shows just how much work is
needed to make sites like this one ready
for people to live in it's understood
here at Raf scampton and Lincolnshire
that migrants will be housed in
temporary accommodation yet to be built
we're actually in the middle of nowhere
here it looks like a town but it's
actually not it's an Airfield and these
are the living quarters for all the crew
and their families and just beyond this
fence Beyond these big hangers is where
the Asylum Seekers are going to be
housed 1500 of them
just right alongside all of these
families who are not happy about it
there's only one shop here and a closed
down Barbers and it's a three mile walk
to the nearest town and residents as
you'd expect are pretty unhappy about
the idea of thousands of people moving
next door the government
to clear the backlog they need to sort
out these people as quickly as possible
so if they're allowed to stay they can
enter the community they can start with
earning a wage and become part of our
society sticking in them on an Airfield
in the middle of nowhere is is not going
to help anyone no one asked you about
your views about this in the last few
weeks no one asked you what you think
about this plan no one's written to you
no no no one's phoned you up and says
look we've got this idea what do you
think nope we heard it all secondhand we
heard all online like everyone else did
and that's how the council found out too
but the government's tough talk on
migration comes just a few weeks before
the local elections the government wants
this to be seen as a No-Frills no spills
approach to housing migrants Nick Martin
Sky News Lincolnshire